so in a year when half of us forgot to
unmute ourselves we were all reminded
about the importance of sound
but we still only talk about watching a
movie we tell people to go and see a
movie but the best films are the ones we
feel
right here i had the privilege of being
taught american sign language for my
role in sound of metal
and what i learned from jeremy my sign
instructor
was that true listening and true
communication goes far beyond what we
hear with our ears
is something we do with our entire
bodies the films nominated tonight for
best sound understood this
they moved us beyond their soundscapes
they soared even in their silences
and they struck us at our core here are
the nominees
for achievement in sound
greyhound warren shaw michael minkler
bo borders and david wyman
mank ren klice jeremy mollod
david parker nathan nance and drew
kunyan
news of the world olivertoni mike
prestwood smith
william miller and john pritchett
seoul ren klice coya elliot
and david parker
sound of metal nicola becker
jaime baxt michel cutolenk carlos cortez
and phillip blood
and the oscar goes too
sound of metal
nicola becca i'm a batch michelle
pizzelle
carlos cortez
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
so uh thank you so much
for the academy for recognizing this
wonderful film
i'm sorry i'm my english is not very
good so that i'm going to read a bit
because i don't want to make problems so
thank you darius and abe
for recognizing this wonderful film no
thank you
darius and abe the true master behind
sound of metal
thank you sasha and bird for your great
support thank you rhys paul and olivia
for
your amazing performances to mikhail for
his collaboration
to philip and jeremy for their
commitments to a key career pia to jana
and their creativity to carolina for her
brilliance to jaime mitchell and carlos
top of the notch
on behalf of philip jaime mitch carlos
and i
i thank you eric mickey roseanne
rosalinda sabina david pablo victoria
cesar chris fannie martin
orlando bruno carla constance anton
and erin we are five in the team that's
why it's a bit long
so now i would like to say something
more personal
fellaini once said in the history of
cinema beyond the evolution of styles
and techniques what stays embodied in
films
is their human vitality and whoever
enjoys it receives a charge of energy
something pulsing
mysterious and vibrant some sound of
metal i receive
from its team so much care love and
attention
so much energy that we believe it's one
of the reason why the film
has been received by the audience so
beautifully
so thank you for that thank you very
much